sh
o
all right maybe um it's a good time to
get uh started uh welcome back everyone
to the fifth and final day of uh this
boot camp uh we have had a really
exciting uh week of talks uh we have
seen talks on um theoretical works on
fundamental aspects of coding Theory we
have seen beautiful codes which Drive
cloud storage something we use every day
uh We've also seen beautiful Theory
which you know for future istic
potential with Quantum error correction
and Quantum Computing and for our final
topic uh we have something which is uh
pretty remarkable which is really
beautiful Theory which is also in uh you
know just over a decade made it into
practice something most of us carry in
our hands uh 5G phones and that is polar
codes and I'm very happy um that Sino
Wang who's a post do here and also uh
Simon's fellow this semester is here to
give us a two-hour tutorial on Polar
codes okay so thank you for coming and
uh really happy to be here um so here's
the poal tutorial they are I think um oh
immediately it doesn't work so there are
I think two sides of a pol Cod there's
an inside and young side so uh on the
inside there is an engineering aspect of
polar code where people deal with list
de coder and people deal with all the
implementation and so if you're
interesting in the uh in the engineering
engineering side and as well as the
future of polar code especially its
position in 6G and also its origin story
and I promise that the original story is
very interesting um you can check aram's
tutorial um he's very good at explaining
what polar code is um so about nine
years ago he has uh been here to to
explain poo and don't forget to
subscribe and click the like button uh
after you check out the toor your
support is very important to us and your
action will tell the YouTube algorithm
that this is the correct video uh to
recommend to more people okay back to
the talk so um that's the uh engineering
side and on my side today I want to talk
about the theory part uh of polar code
and then I'll uh present the
mathematical argument that you can uh
reason about PO Code and you use these
mathematical argument to uh prove the
asmic behavior of code and also um maybe
if there are time um we'll talk about
the versatality of polar
Cod so let's begin with the the core
question what's so Innovative about
polar codes
um and and here's my answer essay so uh
on the left hand side you see a movie
poster this is a I think 2019
documentary about shanan published by
the i e uh society which says that um
Shannon is the bit player so basically
shanon tells us that if you can
manipulate bits if you can tell us a way
to change one symbol into another symbol
then you can do
coding but on the other side uh polar
code is different because polar code
deal with not the bits symbols but
channels so in the way uh people doing
polar code is like the channel player
and so just to show you the point uh
let's play with the most easiest channel
the binary eraser
channel so this is binary eral Channel
you you have a channel and then uh the
input could be zero and one if the input
is zero there's a one minus P
probability that the output is zero and
there's a p probability that the output
is uh erased uh if the input is one the
same thing happen except that the output
is one instead of zero with probability
one minus P so that's binary ratio
Channel and then we start building our
interesting circuit around this channel
so here we have I have two bits um U1 uh
and
U2 and I'm going to put U1 U2 into a
circuit where um it will for it will
multiply that vector by a matrix one
one1 and then uh I'm going to feed X1
and X2 into two copies of binary eral
Channel whose ercial probability is 40%
and then I'll get the output y1 and
Y2 and then our first task is given the
output y1 and Y2 how can we estimate
U1 okay I want to express U1 as a
function of y1 and
Y2 and you probably know the answer so
uh the answer is that you wire the
circuit like this and then you say why 1
plus Y2 will be my estimate of
U1 and so if y1 and Y2 are both not
erased then you can compute U1 in this
way but if one of them is erased then
you just lost the information and so we
kind of conclude that with probability
uh 36% you will get U1 back but with the
other 64% probability you will get an
eraser because the either y1 or Y2 is
erased okay so we say that this is a
binary eraser Channel with eral
probability 64% so so you see that I
kind of generate a new channel out of
two old
channels okay so that's our first task
our second task is that suppose that
there is a genie that tells us the
correct value of U1 after you submit a
guess of U1 okay so it's like the the
professor that tells you the answer
after you take the ex the professor
never tells you the answer before you
take the exam which is nasty okay so now
you want to estimate You2 given uh the
channel observations y1 Y2 and also the
information provided by the genie uh
which is the correct value of U1 okay so
so how are you going to estimate well
there are at least two ways so so the
first uh the first method is that U2 is
going to be y1 plus U1 if y1 is not
erased Okay so if y1 is not erased you
will just use this value uh uh to to
estimate U2 and then the other method is
to use Y2 as an estimate of U2 so there
are two ways to to
estimate U2 and so you can conclude that
you can get back get U2 back with
probability 84% because you only need
one of y1 and Y2 to recover U2 and with
the other 60% chance you get nothing
and we say that this is a binary eral
Channel with eral probability 16% where
16 is like the product of 40% and 40%
trivial uh probability Theory but still
it has good
impact okay so so so we have encountered
our first challenge like uh what why can
we use a genie because we're talking
about codes that are used in uh the real
life and in real life there's no Genie
you have to take all the information and
then make up your own
decision so here's the answer um there
are three cases uh the first case is
that when I estimate U1 I actually get
the correct U1 so U1 head equals U1 in
this case the genie doesn't provide any
useful information because I already
know the answer if y1 and Y2 are not
erased then of course I know U1 and of
course I have a 100 100% confidence that
this U1 is correct so
Genie doesn't need to be there
in case two I estimate you one
incorrectly um so in this case the genie
does provide some information he kind of
correct me that my U1 uh is not correct
or in this case because we're talking
about eror General it tells me the
answer when OIC was
eraser but in this case I argue that the
geni also doesn't help because
eventually we're going to give up the
whole block uh because I have already
made one mistake so this is a very
important point in polar code um uh when
you run this decoder this decoder is
called a successive cancellation decoder
you'll find that you will give up the
whole block after you made the first
mistake so what happened next doesn't
matter so that's the second case that I
argue that the Gen is doesn't help and
the third case is an interesting case
where uh the sender will always send U1
equals zero okay so this is like part of
the protocol that U1 will always be zero
and in this case the best estimation of
U1 is just zero okay so uh this bit has
a special name this is called a frozen
bit anytime there's a bid where uh the
sender and the receiver agrees that they
will always send zero sometimes they
will agree that they will always send
one depending on the situation but uh
when this happens this is called a
frozen bit and when there is a frozen
bit you go back to case one because you
always know the correct value of U1 and
and in this case the genie doesn't
help so let's conclude that Genie is
just a proof technique it help us
understand pood theoretically and then
we kind of leave the implementation to
the
engineers but if you are really really
interesting in the uh uh actual
implementation here is a comparison so
uh uh on the first half of the figure I
I I present you the virtual version of
the decoder and then in the actual
version of the decoder we just use our
estimation of U1 as if it's the true
value of
U1 okay so you can see that uh in in
this
case uh I estimate You2 by adding U y1
and U1 but in the previous case I'm
using uh the true value of U1 so there's
a there's a difference but eventually
when we are analyzing this code this
doesn't make a difference
I need to find a way to advance to the
next p okay good okay and then there is
a um there's another little subtle
detail that in the actual decoder there
is a third phase where the decoder will
pull U1 and U2 from the right hand side
and send it to the left hand side of the
decoder okay and uh for for those who
cannot follow it's okay uh we will only
focus on the uh the decoder but uh for
those who follows uh we will see the
reasons why in the next couple
minutes so it's not important the
implementation detail we're going to put
that on a rug and we're going to start
from scratch so the the the abstraction
that makes makes our life easier is that
we will assume that uh there are two
eraser channels and then there are two
magical devices the red device and the
yellow device and the Magical devices
are such that the output will follow the
distribution that looks like binary
eraser Channel whose eral probability is
2 Z minus Z squ and another eraser
Channel with Z Square so that's the rule
and if we apply the rule to Binary
journal with probability 40% then we
will get 60 ports per and 16% so that's
exactly what we have uh in a couple
minutes ago
okay so the interesting part of this uh
magical device's narrative is that I can
copy this configuration so now I have
two copies of what I have in the
previous slide and then they will
produce four erasor channels 64% 16% 64%
and
16% and then I'll do some uh magical
wiring so by by forwarding this 16% to
this place I can gather the 64% together
and then I can gather the 16% together
and then I can add one more layers of
the magical devices okay so so think
about what happens here
um
the this is this wire is a is a is a
symbol whose ercial probability is 60%
and this wire is another symbol with
probability 60% so for this device he he
sees that the input is two symbols with
iral probability 60% so he can apply the
2 Z minus z s rule to generate new
channels where the iral probability are
2 56 which is 16% squar or twice the 16%
minus its squar and then you can do the
same calculation you'll find that these
are the correct numbers of the eral
channels so given the sorry yeah um is
it true that that uh if I look at the
sum of like all the eral probabilities
of the channels on the right that always
equals the sum of what I started with
yes correct very good observation so
this is because there's an
easier uh explanation to that so 2 Z
minus z s plus Z square is going to be 2
Z so yeah so this always happen this is
a conservation law of entropy we we we
never lose any capacity by doing this
kind of shenanigan yes thank you for
asking
so
okay so we are here and then we said
that we generate four channels and then
we go one step further we're going to
prepare two copies of what we have
before and then we kind of wire that in
this uh funny way so that
87% and 87% are gathered together and
then 40 and 40 29 29 2.2 and then we
will put one more layers of uh devices
to generate new channels as
follows okay so at this point you might
ask doesn't that makes the problem more
difficult because we begin with uh
binary reg with ir probity 40% and now
we have like eight times uh more
channels to deal with so how is that
going to
help well it's going to help because
there's a interesting structure on the
line uh namely uh this tree where you
start with one channel and then you kind
of uh synthesize two new channel and for
either of the channel you kind of
synthesize to new channnel and so on and
so forth so there is a infinet Tre
structure underlying this uh decoder
graph so uh couple minutes ago we said
that um um uh people doing people doing
PO Code is like the channel player but a
more precise statement is that we are
growing trees of channel so in the way
we are the channel Gardener so
um so let's look at a very large tree I
say okay we we we are very patient and
then we apply the uh channnel evolution
rule for six layers so now we have 64 uh
channels and now I we have a 604 times
the problem that I start with so how is
that going to
help and here's the reason so if you
look at these Channel you'll find That
these channels all have iraal
probability less than 1% so suddenly we
begin with the channel That is unusable
and then now we have channels whose iral
probability at 1% which means that I can
just send my message through these
channels without really worrying about
it getting erased it's only 1% chance
yes how sensitive are these encodings to
slight
correlations in in the binary rer
channels so instead of we take assume
maximal Independence where we have
slightly not independent is it still
resilient is it still res I think so yes
yes but you have to quantify yeah well I
guess I guess you could do like
co-variance right and then but do you
have any intuition why you think it's
still
resilient because you just I I guess you
can always measure like U so so you can
do something like here are the two
channels and then you replace the second
Channel by an independent
copy of a by a independ by a copy that
is identical to the second Channel but
independent of the first channel and
then you kind of measure its distance so
there is a way because this because this
channel evolution is very
straightforward there's a way to control
that oh if you have a distance relation
here then then you have another distance
relationship and you kind of bound
everything with inequality but I to be
honest I don't think that will work in
long term because there are going to be
many many layers So eventually you will
lose all the independency but on the
other hand uh you can just do the
simulation and if it works it works so
yeah um I mean in real life there's a um
every channel has interference but we
still ass some IID because it's easier
to analyze so uh thank you for asking
and let's resume so so these channels
are very good channels and then we can
kind of send our message uncoded message
we don't have to do anything we just
send it and hope that the message go
through and what about the other
channels well the other channels are the
bad channels so we use so we kind of
freeze them and by freezing them I mean
we kind we apply the old protocol where
the receiver and the sender both agree
that they will send zero through these
channels so the receiver always knows
these channels and if they know these
channels it's kind of like the genie
tells him the answer and so he
can by knowing the answer of the
channels that are frozen he can decode
the channels that are very good so
that's the essence of polar
code and uh uh so so so a more formal
statement is approved by Aran which
somehow goes like this is if if after
you synthesize two to the nend power of
channels K of them have eral probability
less than P then polar code has code
rate k / by 2 to the n and block error
probability K * P or less
okay so um so let's go back to the tree
and then we look at the the the numbers
of the the channels um we mentioned
before That these channels are very good
channels but on the other hand you also
see channels that are very bad so these
channels are uh have iral probability
that are very close to 100% meaning that
almost always you will never ever be
possible to send an information through
these channels
so what what so so so then the the the
problem is what what about the the
channels in the middle right they are
like onethird of the channels that are
in the middle that are either good
neither good or bad so what happened to
them
okay what happened to them is that if
you kind of be NE be patient and then
you apply more devices to the
tree then eventually you will get a
picture that looks like this where most
of the channel is set very few infection
most of the channels are either uh iral
probability zero or iral probability
100% okay so this is uh this is this
phenomenon is called CH Channel
polarization so if you go back to the
paper where Aran invented polar code he
doesn't mention polar code in the title
what he discovered is that uh there is
the phenomenon where channels polarize
that is kind of a universal property and
then based on this property polar code
uh is a
consequence okay so that kind of explain
the name of polar
code okay so the next thing want to do
is to prove polarization why do we want
to prove polarization well because in
the previous slide we want to use the
good channels to transmit informations
and and so I I I want as much as many
good channels as possible and also this
may sound IR ironic but I also want as
many bad channels as possible
okay why does why is that the case well
because you know the sum is going to be
two to the end times the beginning iraal
probability so by having a lot of
channels grabbing as much iraal
probability as possible you are left
with good channels only so so really you
want both things to happen you want bad
channels and then you want good channels
and then the the the least thing you
want is channels that haven't decided if
he wants to go bad or go good
so that's our goal here we want to prove
polarization so um uh let's review this
is the the rule and then we said that
level n is the two n two to the nend
channels uh that are generated at level
n and then we hope that most B raal
channel in level n are BC whose iral
probability are very close to zero or
one so this is our goal and our
rule okay so the idea here the technique
is to use gen inequality uh in the
following
way so uh uh so this is a convex
function you take a convex function I
hope you have I I believe you have seen
this
before you take a convex function and
then you say uh this this Z value will
become Z squ and 2 Z minus Z Square in
the next iteration and in the next
iteration if you evaluate the the convex
function at these two point the average
will be uh less than what you begin with
and so you can conclude that uh if you
sum all the age at level n and then you
treat this whole thing as a as a
function in N then it will decrease as n
goes to Infinity okay so and then
because this is a complex function it
will definitely decrease and because it
decrease it will imply
polarization okay so let's review our
goal is to prove polarization and then
the idea is to use Jens
inequality but then what is the convex
function we want to use we can use any
convex function but there are good
convex function and bad convex function
so what's a good convex function well
here I convex you mean
concave convex yeah yeah
yeah no can
remember con sorry
sorry it's interesting because the
Chinese character that means K looks
like
this and and concave for the other way
never mind
um okay so so so so this is our concave
I'll just give you a a concrete example
this is very easy to work with right
it's just Z * 1 minus Z and raised to
some power everyone knows how to
evaluate this function um and then I'll
bound this quotient so h of Z squ Plus h
of 2 Z minus Z s/ 2 h of Z so what does
it mean is like this is is the average
this plus this over two is the average
of the new point and then this is like
the old point so I'm Computing the
quotient and then I via some uh computer
programming You can conclude that this
quotient is less than
0.832 and so you can conclude that if
you take the average of all the H values
at level n the average the average will
be 0.832 to the N power so some magical
number and then some magical exponent
and exponential decay so that's what we
can conclude at this
point so here's a a a
[Music]
interesting uh representation of what we
are doing so far because the average is
going to be exponential low it means
that most of the channels are either on
this side or this side there can be only
very few channels exponentially few okay
so so
um so we want to prove polarization and
then we want to apply gen inequality and
then we want to find a a good convex
function and then the convex function is
this particular function Z * 1 minus Z
raised to certain
power and then we go back to Aron the
the theorem says that if there are if k
out of two n channels are less than p in
iraal probability then polar code has
this particular code rate and this
particular aror probability and now we
can conclude that the code rate is going
to be the channel capacity minus some
exponential decaying function and also
we can conclude that the error is going
to be some uh the bit error probability
is going to be some exponentially Decay
function because you just apply the mark
of inequality to uh to the inequality at
the
bottom okay so this is what you can
conclude we are already approaching the
capacity so we have proved something uh
kind of non-trivial uh maybe it's
straightforward but it's very hard to
come up with this whole idea including
all the implementation of pool so maybe
this is a good time to take a stretching
break you know get some coffee watch
some TV um waste 30 minutes of your life
and come back to see what you prove and
you realize that there's a very ser
serious problem in this slide and the
serious problem is that I said that the
I said that the block error probability
is less than KP where k p is some
exponentially Decay function but K is
about the size of 2 N okay so this this
product is going to be some exponential
decay function times 2 N which is going
to be greater than one okay so if you if
you prove something and if you prove
that the error probability is less than
one it's kind of you know it's like a
trivial result like we are not proving
anything although we have spent a lot of
effort so our next
job is to uh improve P right we want to
um we want to build on top of this LMA
and then we want to prove that we can uh
make p even
[Music]
smaller so let's improve
P so this is our rule in casee you
forget and I'm going to plot uh the the
Z how does how the ercial
probability evolute uh in terms of n so
you begin with 40% and then you get um
what's that 16% and 64% and then you
kind of uh apply the rule again and
again and again and then I'm going to
put a forbidden zone at this place okay
so how how do I Define this zone is that
I'll put a vertical line at level and
half and then I'll put two horizontal
line at Z equals some exponential small
number and Z equals 1 minus some
explanation number and then I'm going to
call this for forbidden zone and then
I'm going to say be by the by the thing
we just
prove there is a exponential decaying
fraction of channels that have been
inside this forbidden
zone because we just what what do we
just prove with the convex function
concave okay concave function is that um
uh uh there are very few channels
staying in the middle in terms of their
uh ercial probability so there are very
few channels that stays in the forbidden
zone and now we focus on the channels
that are below uh the forbidden zone we
focus on on the channels that that kind
of enter through this small door and
then stays here and not touching not not
getting into the zone and then we we we
we see that these channels will
undergo and half Evolution n half
Channel Evolution and out of this n half
Channel Evolution every time you make a
choice between z s and 2 Z minus Z
Square so half of the time you will
Square your
itself okay and squaring is a very
powerful uh operation because it makes a
very small number even more
smaller and doubling a number would just
be like making it a little bit larger
okay so if we apply the whole thing
inequality we can say that most channels
under the forbidden zone will underg go
Z map to Z Square squaring this many
times and have and and over five times
so something less than n over four is
good and if they Square themselves uh n
over five times then the Z value will
become the value that you begin with
raised to the power of two to the power
of n to the
5 and that is about 2 to
the2 uh to the power of n over five so
this is like a doubly exponential decay
function in terms of n
okay so so we go back to the theorem
statement we just prove
uh uh if k out of the two end channels
are less than P the polar code has code
rate K over two to the n and block a
probability KP where the code rate is
some is the capacity minus some
exponential decay function and then we
have improved our error probability from
uh exponential decay to double
exponential decay okay and because we
have proved that the error probability
is double exponential
decay this quantity is going to be W
exponential decay because this will
dominate K okay so that term will be
that term will eventually become the
main term of the error of polar
code okay so let's review uh in the
beginning we want to prove
polarization uh and then we say we want
to apply gen sens quality and then we
kind of pick a concave function and then
we say that this is our concave function
and then we say that oh p is too bad so
uh we want to improve p and then we use
hting inequality to improve P so
um uh they so so we kind of we kind of
stop here and then say uh here is a very
beautiful theorem but then the problem
is can you generalize this theorem can
you improve all the constants within
this theorem uh and can you generalize
this to more channels and so on and so
forth sorry yeah yeah I don't know if
you said this maybe I missed it but is
there any like intuition to the Z time
oneus to the weird power here is it just
is it any ination so um so the first
thing you try is z minus one minus
z z * 1 minus Z right it's a it's a very
symmetric uh concave function and then
you realize that some something bad
happens at the feet of the
heel okay so so if you try Z * y minus Z
this this segment will be
linear right so and if you compute the
question say Al so so linear function
apply to Z and linear function of Z
square and linear function applied to 2D
minus Z Square will be their average so
that part isn't very con convex so um
you have to bend it and the way to bend
it is to apply a non-trivial
power people have people have tried many
ideas but like this this is not a very
easy to come up with like all the
magical uh exponent but so so the
magical exponent is
like you want to find an easiest
function because um if you want to prove
the estimate if you want to prove this
estimate rigorously you have to apply
some interval arithmetic stuff and so
you will want to uh you will want to use
a function that is very simple in form
so you kind of start optimizing for the
Simplicity instead of optimizing for the
best quantity or of course you want to
optimize both that's basically what
happened and then uh you can try two3
you can try other powers but this one
will
work
okay
so that's what we have and uh this is
the our process and then we're kind of
like projecting into the future like oh
we want to uh do more about polar
code so there are uh many many topics
that you can explore in polar code so uh
the basic of polar code is uh is
consists of two things a successive
cancellation decoder which is the
decoder I introduced uh in the beginning
of the talk and then we have observed a
phenomenon code Channel
polarization and then our goal is to uh
prove better Gap to capacity and better
error
probability and they are generalizations
of polar code U first of all you can use
a larger
Matrix or and then if you if you allow
yourself for a larger Matrix maybe you
can use res solement Matrix as the
kernel of the Polar Cod I'll explain
that data but but just keep in mind with
this and then we can also generalize
polar code to General channels like a
BMS binary memoryless symmetric Channel
and also Channels with larger
alphabet we can also consider pooc code
over multiple asset Channel broadcast
channel wir tab Channel lossy
compression lossless compression
distributed compression so on and so for
comparing with helpers so on and so for
uh we can also consider Quantum channels
we can also consider Channels with
synchronizing
errors and we can also consider coded
computation and the last thing is like U
something new we can also consider
pre-coded polar code where before you
incode the polar code you multiply the
message vector by a lower triangular
Matrix and then you apply this decoding
to to to
decode so let's uh let's look at the
better cap Gap to capacity part
um so in couple slides ago I said that
if you bound this quotient you'll get a
fraction that is uh uh that is about 0.2
32 but this is not the um this is not
the optimal value because if you look at
this quoti you will see if you if you
look at this qu and you plot in terms of
Z you will see that there is a curve and
so your job is to kind of fine-tune the
H such that the curve become flat and if
the if the quotient curve become flat it
means that this quantity is optimal
and so the method that can help you
optimize H is is that you use power
method so you start with you start with
this H where H zero is going to be this
function and then you apply this so uh
the new H the new function H is going to
be the evaluation of the old function at
Z squ and the evaluation at 2 Z minus Z
squ and then you multiply that by a
normalized factor so by applying this
power method you can kind of flatten the
quotient curve and when you flatten the
quotient curve the numerical value will
become something that is very close to
the optimal
value but there is a problem here so so
first of all for any non-trivial
function finding the supremum over uh Z
in the interval 01 is going to be highly
non-trivial if you want to do it
rigorously because you don't of course
you don't want to do it by hand so you
do it on the computer and then you have
to make sure the computer doesn't choose
the good Z's to evaluate you have to
kind of certify that on the whole
interval this quantity is less than uh
the estimate the estimation we want to
prove so that's the so that's the open
problem one and then the open problem
two is like why does power method even
work like we cannot explain why power
method would we cannot explain why power
method will converge to
the optimal function that gives us the
optimal scaling
exponent and
so
uh and if and if we cannot if we cannot
kind of prove that the power method
converge we cannot prove that in theory
ex the exponential constant
exist so maybe maybe the optimal
constant here is like an interval that
depends on the channels you are using
okay so that's the uh that's the open
problems that are remain in the
air okay so so so we talk about how to
prove better Gap to capacity and now
we're talking about how to prove better
error
probability
okay so let's go back to this figure
where um where we kind of put a
forbidden zone here and and then we say
that oh by applying hting inequality to
this quantity we will uh we we we we can
square the Z and depending on how many
times we Square the Z we can prove good
error probability so what we do now is
instead of pro putting the the vertical
point at n half I'm going to put the
vertical point at
N3 so pushing that toward the left so
this means that um I'm going to draw the
horizontal line with a with a worse
constant and then I'm going to conclude
that 2 to the uh negative Omega n over
three fraction of channels have been
here so this is a a worse estimation of
the numbers of channels that haven't
that have been into the forbidden
zone and then I apply the same whole
thing inequality again but this time I
will get a new constant which is 1/3
minus Epsilon because now we are we are
undergoing squaring or doubling more
times so there are more squaring to to
do and if there are more squaring to do
it means that you can so you start with
a very small quantity and then you
square it Square it Square it it will
become smaller smaller smaller and then
you kind of square it one3 n
times and if you can if you can push so
this is this is what happen if you put
this line at N3 if you put this line at
n over five or n / 10 you will you can
you can improve this quantity and then
if you put the line all the way to to
this place that is very very close to
where you begin then what happen is that
you will have a very bad estimate here
and here and here these are going to be
not exponential decay because you just
put them at a very beginning so this
this quantity becomes like some constant
so your Gap to capacity becomes constant
but then your error probability this
place this will become 1/2 and so your
error probability will become two to the
two to the N
half so double exponential decay where
the explicit exponent is
1/2 so so this is the the the the kind
of like the the summary of what we what
we can prove we can show that The Gap to
capacity is about 2 to the N ided by 3.6
to7 so this is like the optimal constant
if you apply the power method and then
if you do all the floating Point
computation you get this
constant and then you can show
that uh the error probability is two to
the 2 to the -2 to some multiple of N
and then you can improve that constant
to one minus 12 minus Epsilon but if you
want to do that if you were to do that
it means that you will lose some
capacity some Gap to capacity okay so
there is the trade of either you have
this very good Gap to capacity but
satisfactory error probability or you
have some constant Gap to capacity and
very good
error okay so uh I'm I'm going to call a
stop here and uh so in in the next hour
we we're going to cover uh the other
topics of this
graph we suddenly have time for
questions um so there so you say it at
the end like you know the best possible
Gap F you get was like this two to the
minus n BL this is like with these
methods is it provable like if you use
this like rule for combining channels in
this way you can't do like better than
certain Gap to capacity like is there
some sort of lower bound on the Gap to
capacity that you would need so you can
turn
this so so this is an inequality here
but if this somehow becomes
equality then it's kind of
optimal
so uh you need to work out the detail
but I think this is optimal for this
particular case so because for this
particular case we know exactly these
Val what these values are so you just
turn your computation upside down then
it becomes an opun
computation so I think if your rate is
between Z and one then your minimum
distance is square in then you get
exactly that as a l down right because
you're getting like two the minus S
capital sure so the minimum distance
yeah I think that is for the error
probability maybe he's asking about the
Gap to capacity I think probility yeah
yeah I understand yeah the capacity that
doesn't mean yeah the error rate that
doesn't make sense yeah
yeah any other
questions I had a question about the
open problem for the that
recursion uh the TR yeah trying to get
it so I mean this is actually an Iden
value problem on this space of like say
continuous functions from zero and I
feel I feel like there's under mild
conditions um that you know that what's
going to happen to this but finding the
function um I think is hard or perhaps
impossible right I don't know why you
you're not sure the power meas will work
what do you mean by work there's just no
you you so for power meth you need some
kind of like Contraption
map you need to find a metrix and you
kind of say that oh this function this
Con sequence of function becomes a Coy
sequence and so on and so forth because
it could just jump
so like very crazy it could suddenly
becomes very un incontinuous yeah and
you have no way to bound that of course
your belief it's not the case
but okay yeah but in this case if you
just simulate this for a bunch of steps
do you get that function the no no this
is not even accurate this is
like so so so there is a tailor
expansion thing so you start with this
as a base and then there's like
a whole ex expansion in terms of so you
are you are you are expanding this
function in terms of this variable you
you use a symmetric variable Z * 1 minus
Z and then you do the tailor expansion
and then you can kind of like you use
some fitting library to make it to the T
power but you can't see any pattern
there yeah but if you just plot it with
Mathematica you see it gets pretty flat
the the quo will get very flat but then
edges the The Edge will be rough like
maybe maybe so so if you so if you write
the program that optimize for all the
coefficients you will get certain
quantity and then the tailor expansion
and then this will be very flat and then
there is like range effect or something
like that so what you can do is to you
you modify this exponent such that the
function behaves better at the two ends
so you kind of bend it even further then
then the rough effect will goes away
because you just the rough effect you
just uh press that down and you will
have you don't have to wor about that
but then the question is how much do you
have to bend the function like you have
to make it quantitative otherwise it
doesn't
count you can also Imagine doing this
for two steps and writing a more complex
function with four terms and yes yes so
you will be like so you can
uh yeah so so so if there are four terms
then maybe it will it will give you a
better result but maybe it will not so
then that's not being tried or like it's
for for this case we kind of believe
that this is optimiz so we don't try for
this case but for other case we try and
it there are cases where it give you a
better uh estimate we will we can cover
that uh
later other questions
all right not let's take a break and we
are back here at
[Applause]
11:00